a new children's book series and brand
is inspiring even the pickiest of eaters
to try new foods it is being backed by
some culinary icons all in an effort to
bring people together not just around
the table but around the world when
people ask if I'm kalamata I always like
no she's so much cooler than me
cooler maybe but her childhood alter ego
may have a tough time competing with
Sarah Thomas's unparalleled palette as
sommelier two world renowned restaurant
Le Bernadin in Manhattan
Thomas's hands were already full
matching taste to type his city still
she and partner Derek Wallis dreamed up
this heroine food adventurer everybody
has a food memory and everybody wants to
share that food memory and Kalamata
wants to go on adventure inspired by
that food memory do you see the
significance of Kalamata being a
non-traditional character on paper she's
gonna be brown yep and she's gonna be
curly-haired when did that germinate I
think it was pretty immediately this
idea that we could bring people together
through food there's a lot of things in
the world I think that are teaching
adults about that but there was nothing
that was really effectively bridging
that for children and helping them
understand how they could learn about
new flavors and places and cultures in
the series Kalamata
and her friend al dente the alligator
tries sophisticated fare with some
pretty famous friends including Thomas's
boss libera Dan's co-owner Erik repair
one of the world's most awarded chefs I
would have loved to be first but it was
already a Kalamata book I was happy to
be the number two I mean it's almost
like she's opening up a whole new
audience for people like you so you mean
she's working on my next client and yes
I like that it's going to create a
generation of young people will have
appreciation for the planet for the
bounty of what we can find and
for good food and for interacting with
people the book looks like is a children
book and it is but it's much more
powerful on that it's creating the
future in many many ways for repair
calamara carries on a tradition he had
with his son Adrian I wanted to aim to
be exposed to a lot of different
cultures and to be excited about eating
different ingredients not I see so many
kids they eat only pastime and french
fries and hot dogs some of them and I
didn't want that fall for my son I will
say to him we are going to open a
restaurant tonight and you are going to
be the maitre d and you are going to be
my sous chef as well you have to decide
what you want to eat we're going to
travel the world and then you will be in
charge of creating the menu you will me
a little bit with the shopping and so on
and then we eat together as a family and
he was so excited about that Kalamata
has generated that kind of excitement
with tasting events in several cities
but it's more than just books there is a
line of kitchen ready products for kids
and kalamatas city guides maps to
family-friendly eateries that treat kids
like VIPs it's a mission rooted in
Thomas's childhood what was it like as a
kid for you there weren't a lot of
people who whose families were like mine
we're pretty traditionally Indian but we
were born in the United States and he
first-gen kids are always sort of
spanning this like where do I really
belong and how do I fit in the thing
that was always that was always I always
could come home to was that my mom
cooked all the time that smells of my
childhood all of her South Indian
cooking being in the kitchen with her
sitting in the kitchen reading while she
was cooking like those things made such
a strong impression on me as a child
loyalty to that memory inspired what
Wallace has dubbed the tastebud pledge I
promise to keep my mind open in my fork
ready to try each new food at least two
times and share what's on my plate when
someone doesn't have enough and that
everything that we stand for in one
sentence is that it's here I get
emotional I get emotional when I talk
about it that the people we get to work
with as a result of the some of them are
our heroes literally it's the best work
that we've all ever done and if you
don't we don't want to stop doing it for
Thomas it's all about expanding
kalamatas circle of friends who's on the
list well I mean Kalamata is definitely
friends with Michelle Obama I don't know
if Michelle Obama knows that yet but
right now they might just be going on a
food adventure already and we just need
to I just need to write that stories and
she will I have to tell you I went to of
one of these food tastings with the kids
and it's they will taste but they'll
tell you what they really think I mean
they may not like it but just the these
they have being around this fancy food I
can't imagine kids speaking their minds
what's cool is that they have the
guidebook to for parents to go to the
restaurants in these cities with kids
where the kids are gonna be taken care
of and you know you're gonna be yeah
welcome yeah my nephew is a very picky
eater so mark and Stacia don't worry
you're getting a book all of you to take
the taste bud challenge I love it it's
it's a wonderful thing